Here are a few tips that don't take a lot of time...
...but can have huge security benefits.
First, check if your data has been leaked.
The website Have I Been Pwned has a database of information that has been exposed.
You can input your info like an email address or old passwords...
...to see if that data has been leaked.
If it has, change those passwords right away.
Use a password manager, like LastPass or 1Password.
A password manager securely stores your passwords...
...and can help you generate unique ones that are hard to crack with brute-force hacking.
Additionally, setting up two-factor authentication for your accounts...
...can prevent someone who has that password from accessing that account.
If you're feeling overly vulnerable or paranoid,...
...you can even purchase a device like YubiKey...
...to add even more security to your accounts.